treat yourself like you're someone that
you care about I read this piece of work
by Jill a long while back and it was a
meditation on the injunction to treat
your neighbor as as you would like to be
treated and what Jung pointed out which
I really liked was that that wasn't an
injunction to be nice to other people it
was an invitation to reciprocity it was
something like this it's like you should
figure out how you would like to be
treated like you were taking care of
yourself not how you would like people
to respond to you it's more important
than that it's like imagine you had a
child that you really cared for and and
someone said people will treat this
child exactly like you want them to but
you have to figure out what that is and
so then you'd have to sit down for like
a month and you'd think okay well how do
you want your child to be treated you
don't want everyone just to be nice to
them you know you want people to
challenge them and you want people to
discipline them and want people to tell
them when he's wrong it's like you don't
just want everyone to be nice that's
pathetic there's no challenge in that
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because when I started my
first business I really struggled to
believe myself I was making 300 bucks a
month and quit on my business partner
and the thing that say me was watching
the stories of successful entrepreneurs
they gave me strategies as well as hope
and belief that just maybe I could do it
myself as well and I hope that this
video here today helps you get a little
bit more belief in yourself because I
still need the videos for myself today
too so today let's learn Jordan
Peterson's advice to improve your life
right now
enjoy
and so
well you want to treat other people like
you would like to be treated well then
you have figured out how would you like
to be treated
and while you'd like people to farm all
over you and just lay everything at your
feet it's like no
that's not something you'd wish for for
someone that you were taking care of and
then then there's an additional problem
which is it's often the case that people
will treat other people better than they
treat themselves that happens extremely
frequently so one of the things I
pointed out chapter two was that
if you have a dog and you take him to a
vet and the vet gives you your
prescription medicine you'll go buy the
medicine and you will give it to the dog
and you will do it properly but if you
go yourself to a doctor and you get a
prescription there's one that there's a
30 chance you won't even pick up the
medication and if you do there's a 50
chance that you won't administer it to
yourself properly
and so I really thought about that when
I first came across that statistic it
really it was another one of those
little facts I thought what the hell's
up with that it's like you'll do it for
your dog so obviously you'll do it for
something you care about and your
conscientious enough so you'll actually
do it so like why wouldn't you do it for
you your dog likes you you know even
your dog would rather that you did but
but you don't you don't and and it's
actually one of the reasons that modern
medicine doesn't work nearly as well as
it could because people just don't take
their medication you make the world a
much better place a much worse place if
you don't take care of yourself
so you should bloody well take care of
yourself you know because
well that's what the chapter is about
it's partly because you have something
valuable to bring into the world
that's the thing about being an
individual it's the thing that Western
Civilization has always recognized that
as an individual you have a light that
you have to bring into the world and
that if you don't bring it into the
world the world is a dimmer place and
that's a bad thing because when the
world is a dim place it can get very
very very dark and so it's not just so
that you feel better not just so that
you're a number one Lobster none of
those things you need to take care of
yourself because you're in the best
position to do that and it's necessary
for you to take care of yourself despite
the fact that we're mortal and
vulnerable and self-conscious and
capable not only capable of doing
terrible things but actually do them
despite all that you you're still you
still have that responsibility rule
number two is take responsibility give
advice for young people
in high school you've given a lot of
people look up to you for advice for
strength for
um strength to search for themselves to
find themselves take on some
responsibility
do something for other people
you're doing something for yourself
while you're doing that even if you
don't know it for sure because you're a
community across time
find something to serve
somebody to help someone to help us off
a job to find a job do your best with
the customers don't be above your job
you're going to get an entry-level job
when you're a kid or what else would you
want you want to be the boss what do you
know you don't know anything
you could be the boss of your job
you know if you're working in a grocery
store or you're working in a convenience
store assuming you're not working for
terrified tyrants
you can be nice to the customers you can
develop your social skills you can learn
how to handle boss employee relationship
you can be there 15 minutes early and
leave 15 minutes late like you can learn
in an entry-level job man and I'll tell
you if you take an entry-level job and
you learn and it's a reasonably decent
place you will not be in an entry-level
job for long because everyone who's
competent is desperate for competent
people and if you go and show yourself
as competent there'll be a trial period
but if you go show yourself as competent
all sorts of doors you didn't even know
were there will start opening like mad
see strive for competence
for craftsmanship yeah yep yep for
discipline you know I mean I I said in
one of the chapters my books is is
focused on putting your house in order
it's like well how do you start make
your bed
you know I I it actually took me quite a
long time in my life before I made my
bed regularly in the morning most of my
life whispered in pretty good order but
that was one thing I didn't have in
order my call clothes in my closet as
well all that's in order not all of it
I'm cleaning out some drawers right now
but
look around and see what bugs you in
your room just look it's like okay I'm
in my room do I like this room no it
bugs me okay why well the Pain's peeling
there and it's dusty there and the
carpet's dirty and that corner is kind
of ugly and the light there isn't very
good and my clothes closet's a mess so I
don't even like to open it
um okay that's a lot of problems
that sucks that's a lot of opportunity
pick something and fix it something that
bugs you yeah but not too much so it the
rule is
pick something you know would make pick
a problem
pick a solution to it that you know
wouldn't help
that you could do
that you would do so you have to
negotiate with yourself it's like I
won't clean up this room how do you know
I've been in here for 10 years and I've
never cleaned it up it's like well
obviously that's too big a dragon for
you would you clean one drawer
find out
and so imagine now you want to be happy
when you open that drawer and you think
well that's stupid it's like is it
maybe it's your sock drawer which I
cleaned up in my room the other day by
the way you're gonna you're gonna open
that every morning
so that's like 30 seconds of your life
every day
okay so that's three minutes uh
week that's 12 minutes a month that's
two hours a year so maybe your life is
made out if you've got 16 hours a day
let's figure this out 5 12 in an hour 12
in an hour
144 in 12 hours yeah let's say 200 205
minute chunks that's your life this is
gentlemen Jordan Peterson did just some
math how many five-minute chunks there
are in a day that's pretty accurate it's
approximately right so you got 200 five
minute chunks and they repeat a lot of
them repeat
so if you get every one of those right
they're trivial right who cares what my
sock drawer looks like it's like fair
enough man but that's your life the
things you repeat every day
the mundane things think I could get all
those mundane things right that's the
game rules it's like now the mundane is
in place
now you can play because all the
mundane's in place and this is actually
true so with children
imagine you want your children to play
well play is very fragile neurologically
any competing motivation or emotion will
suppress play
so everything has to be in order
everything has to be a Walled Garden
before the children will play that's a
good way of thinking about it so you put
everything in order and you think oh my
God now I'm tyrannized by this order
it's like no you aren't not if it's
voluntary
and then the order is the precondition
for the freedom
and so then all of a sudden you get all
these things in order it's like oh look
at this I've I've got some room to play
here and then then maybe you're not
depressed no it's it's often not that
simple you know it's not that simple try
putting your room in Order Perfect order
that's hard I mean that's a really
powerful way to think about those five
minute chunks just get one of them right
in a day
yeah well if you do that for 200 days
your life is in order rule number three
is make wise and truthful decisions
there's a saying that says tough times
produce strong men
strong men produce good times good times
produce weak men weak men produce tough
times yes if that's the truth which
phase are we in today
well if you think about it historically
you have to say that we're in good times
I mean
that doesn't mean everything about the
current times are good and of course
life is always tenuous and and and
difficult but it's 1919 if you go back a
hundred years ago imagine what the last
five years would have been like right
you would have been the entire world was
encapsulated in a terrible War the
trench warfare was absolutely brutal and
that was a five-year period and then
that was followed by the Spanish
influenza which killed 120 million
people and you know so I'd rather be
here now than there then by a
substantial margin and
um I think life is never easy uh even
under relatively positive conditions but
um I would say that
it's very difficult to make the case
that we're not in good times and I
especially think that's true if you look
at the world
globally
um the American working class and maybe
the Western working class in general
paid a very large price for enriching
the rest of the world you know I mean
China's come up
in a miraculous way in the last 40 years
South Korea India while the entire South
in all of Southeast Asia and
increasingly Africa too because the
fastest growing economies in the world
are now in sub-Saharan Africa and that's
produced a tremendous competition for
working-class people in the west but
speaking on a global level
there's never been a better time for the
majority of people to be alive and the
future
although
we're vulnerable and terrible things can
always happen to us
it's hard to make a case that the future
doesn't look comparatively positive
we're becoming extremely technologically
sophisticated and the world is changing
at an incredibly rapid rate and the only
way we're going to be able to manage
that in a positive way is if each of us
or as many of us as possible are capable
of making wise and careful and truthful
decisions and if we do that then you
know maybe things can continue to
improve
the rate of absolute poverty in the
world has fell fell by 50 percent
between the year 2000 and the year 2012.
you know that's the fastest rate of
economic Improvement in the history of
the world and and
um
there's plenty of reason to be
optimistic
if you're inclined in that direction
I would say it's best to marry that with
a healthy dose of
attentive caution because
well as I said things can go badly wrong
but
I can't think of a Time
in the past that I would trade for now
despite all the problems that are also
part and parcel of being alive now also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is stop acting
what is the consequence the long-term
consequence of acting so many people
especially because of the worlds I live
in on Instagram and social media we kind
of build out these personas and then we
almost follow the implicit instructions
that come with those personas well
that's the problem right there is that
well that that I'm trying to get a hold
of the Disney people at the moment
because I want to do a lecture series on
Pinocchio because I think Pinocchio is
brilliant work of art
um and
if you're a puppet and an actor and
Pinocchio is both at times in that movie
both a puppet and an actor so why an
actor like why is there why is there
something wrong with being an actor well
the first question is well who sets your
role
and then the second question is who's
pulling your strings so you put on this
front that is there to make you popular
and sexy and desirable and to mask from
yourself your own inadequacies but
that's a role well who wrote it and for
what purpose
and so Jung said for example we all
acted out a myth and whether we knew it
or not and you know maybe you're acting
out a tragedy maybe maybe you're acting
out Narcissus
you don't know
because you've put that you've put that
on yourself in an attempt in some ways
to deliver to people what they want or
more accurately to look as though you're
delivering to people what they want and
it's not nothing to do that right
because at least you're attempting in
some sense to adapt to the social World
someone who's really infantile and
dependent someone who's never left home
part of their problem is that they
haven't crafted a persona
so you don't want to denigrate it
entirely but it's no substitute for the
real thing and it turns out that
not only is what we want from each other
the real thing but that's also the
adventure of your life and so if you
aren't
truthful and that means unfortunately
especially at the beginning when you
start to be truthful it means deeply
coming to terms with your inadequacies
in humility so it's very painful without
that you don't have the adventure of
your life you have the role that has
been that you've
acquiesced to and that'll take all the
meaning out of your life rule number
five is reward yourself in rule two you
say to imagine who we could be and then
to aim single-mindedly at that but
reality gets in the way of you reaching
that potential and it can hurt how can
people cope with the pain of unreached
potential
well part of well that's a really good
question look every ideal is a judge
right so you pause it an ideal and
instantly you're in inferior position in
relationship to that ideal and that can
be crushing okay so what do you do about
that well one answer is no ideals well
that's not a good answer because then
you don't have anything to do
right so so and that deprives you of a
main source of pleasure which is
observed uh generated as a consequence
of observed movement towards a valued
goal so if you have a high goal and you
see any movement towards it there's a
potential there's a really powerful
potential kick there so you don't want
to dispense with that but then if you
set up an ideal it can judge you very
harshly so then you have to rearrange
your reward philosophy and instead of
punishing yourself from as a consequence
of perceived distance you reward
yourself for incremental movement
forward and that's not just theoretical
look I was stopped by three guys on the
street this week three separate
occasions and they all told me the same
thing they you know they they said that
they had read or something I wrote or
listened to something or watched
something and that it had been helpful
and whenever ever anybody says that to
me I always ask them okay exactly what
was helpful and what changed because I
want to know what's helping so that I
can understand the Target and hit it
better and so and generally people are
more are pleased to tell me
um although sometimes it takes them a
while to formulate exactly the
description but they all three of them
said
um I stopped comparing myself to other
people
so I'll stop comparing what I didn't
have to what other people had I left
that off the table and then I started to
reward myself for improving over what I
was yesterday so they and that's
profound change because it means that
you actually get your reward structure
transformed and that's a big deal
because that's that's your source of
positive emotion and enthusiasm
encouragement all of that so now you can
start to encourage yourself for
for genuine Improvement and it's also
pragmatically extremely intelligent
because
incremental Improvement repeated is
virtually Unstoppable and I
that's like the Hallmark of behavioral
therapy that idea because what a
behavior therapist does is you come and
you say to me
I'm not things aren't the way I want
them to be and then I say well well
how would you like them to be and how
are they not that so we lay out the
problem the territory and then the next
thing we do is lay out a trajectory
which is okay well here's something
you're Lonesome you don't have a partner
okay so what are the what are
incremental movements can you make
towards that goal that you would do that
would be helpful and so maybe you you
you negotiate with the person because
that's what you do if you're a
reasonable therapist and you say well
look why don't you uh you decide as a
consequence of the conversation why
don't you write out a description of
yourself for a dating site don't post it
or anything just write it out and and
then let's see if you actually do that
and so then the person comes back next
week and they say I did that and not
only that I posted it and you say great
what's the next step or they say geez
you know I just kept avoiding that
and then you say okay well we need to
break that down
you avoided it well could you write one
sentence about who you are right now
while you're sitting here and sometimes
they can do that right away or sometimes
they can't and then you you make a
microanalysis of that and what you do is
you you reduce the magnitude of the move
forward until you hit the point where
you actually will do it
and that's like the secret to good
negotiation as well if you're
negotiating with your wife maybe you
want one of her behaviors to change
and
then obviously she has to be on board
with that and hypothetically that's
going to be reciprocal process but what
you want to do is find a small
Improvement that is measurable
that's implementable that will be
implemented that you can then reward and
and that's that's that's how you can
have your ideal
you you can have whatever ideal you want
as long as you're willing to reduce your
movement forward to achievable
increments but that's okay because they
compound
so and I really learned this as a
therapist it was one of the things that
was so fun about being a therapist is
you can take someone through this
process and start them on just the
tiniest goal
you know and it just seems trivial but
they'll do it and then they start moving
fast after faster and faster after that
point once once the direction has been
established and people make incredible
improvement over you know uh not
unreasonable spans of time a few months
maybe a few years but which is not
nothing but it's not decades you know
it's
I saw saw that time and time again
so
aim high but reward yourself for small
incremental improvements especially ones
that repeat every day rule number six is
cultivate your own inner peace how do
you cultivate your own personal inner
peace
amongst
the different changes that have come up
whether you know the fame the health
challenges uh personally maybe
challenges with family or friends how do
you personally
keep a level of inner peace amongst the
chaos
I walk a lot I exercise a lot
a lot like I'm walking about seven miles
a day now and working out as well and so
and that's necessary
um
I take solace if you didn't walk and
work out
where do you think you would be
hello really
definitely
yes yes
definitely is that physically because
you wouldn't be physically taking care
of your body or because mentally and
emotionally your piece would be chaotic
and it would drive you to die
that wow
yeah
so that you see you're saying sorry I
was interrupting yourself
peace that comes to you if you're
fortunate
and sometimes it doesn't come
um I try to do things that I think are
worthwhile
that that seemed worthwhile and that
gives me
Solace I suppose yeah
um
so I'm writing I'm talking to people who
I find interesting about things that I
think are crucially important
I'm trying to learn
and to communicate
as a consequence of talking to these
people
um
I'm trying to do what I can for my
family and my friends and to do what I
can beyond that as well in a variety of
different ways
um
those are all useful endeavors
and they keep me going and remember
seven the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is find your Nemesis
do you think that there's a usefulness
in having a nemesis to motivate you
talking about some of the situations
that you've been through not
particularly those ones exactly but
I try to avoid making enemies of people
or groups or ideas or whatever yes don't
make unnecessary enemies but there is an
extra level of fire that gets lit
underneath you when you're going up
against someone and I miss it sometimes
there's a price that you pay for peace
yeah well then you just have to look at
yourself harder and find the nemesis
because it's there all the time right I
mean there's always parts of yourself
that you can overcome
and so that's William James moral
equivalent to war essentially now if you
need something to Grapple with
them you probably do you can find that
you just look inside you'll find
something to Grapple with you know
inadequacy weakness susceptibility to
Temptation narcissism Pride Envy Revenge
resentment frustration lack of faith all
of that that'll keep you occupied if you
really grapple with it and yeah I mean
that's an ancient theological question
you know what's up with the devil why
why is that why does the possibility of
evil exist why is there an eternal
adversary you see that reflected in Cain
and Abel right at the beginning of the
Genesis stories essentially the first
two human beings are good set against an
adversary and that's that's what opens
history that story you think well why
would God construct such a
why would God construct a reality where
an adversary exists and maybe it's
because all things considered a World
with an adversary is a better world just
like a garden with a snake and it is a
better Garden these things aren't easy
to understand
no no snake no necessity to contend with
snakes so why be awake at all
no adversary no challenge why be
challenged because maybe you're better
for the challenge
and maybe that's the challenge to see if
you can be better for the challenge but
that should be internal well
fundamentally well if it isn't you'll
find it externally because you'll
demonize someone to turn them into Satan
so that you can find an adversary and
then that's very unfortunate for you and
for them that's just not as big a battle
it's like you you battle with someone
external who's malevolent let's say or
you think they are and usually you've
got that mostly wrong but not always but
if the battle is inside which is where
it's supposed to be
most fundamentally then
well then it's the ultimate it is the
ultimate Challenge and that's the
infinite game
the external one battle between good and
evil on a playing field of Chaos and
Order that's the Eternal game and you
know you can play that out in the
external world but
part of what the religious Enterprise is
about and the Christians have really
contributed to this is the notion that
that sacred battle is fundamentally
spiritual which is to say in some sense
fundamentally psychological it's to be
it's to be fought on the battleground of
the Soul
internally it's a subjective issue how
do you defeat evil
you defeat the evil in your own heart
that's that is how you do it
and so if that's all being acted out for
you in the world well you you've
misplaced Satan that's a good way of
thinking about it this is another
weakness I think of the atheistic
position because
you can it's pretty hard it's an easy in
some sense to dispense with belief in
the highest good but it's not so easy to
dispense with belief and Evil
so that's a big problem so then where do
you localize it and you can find
evidence of it everywhere certainly in
institutions I mean that's the whole
systemic racism corrupt patriarchy
narrative is that Satan is to be found
at the core of our institutions and to
some degree
that's true because everything we do is
corrupt to some degree and so then do
you fight it sociologically and you're
the good person and the institution is
Satan
so you're so good are you
you're so sure of that are you you've
got everything in order or do you
and you might say well you have to have
everything in order before you fight
evil on the sociological front and the
answer is well no because you're never
going to have everything in order but
you still shouldn't put the cart before
the horse
it's really it's a spiritual battle and
it's taken people thousands and
thousands of years to figure this out
now first of all it was the snake
what's what's evil what's malevolent the
predatory reptile
fair enough man I mean we've been
fighting with predatory reptiles for 60
million years as mammals 60 million
years so it's a good first pass
approximation
it's the snake the poisonous snake the
external enemy The Predator
but what about the predator and other
people
oh yeah that's even worse man it's like
how pretty predators are one thing but
predatory people other tribes men
they're brutal they're brutal
oh well what about your predatory friend
oh that's pretty bad too the friend who
stabs you in the back the person who
betrays you Judas God maybe that's the
ultimate snake it's like well how about
when you betray yourself
oh yeah
so you wanna see there's this
Association that's very strange that
occurred in the development of Christian
thought between the snake and the Garden
of Eden and Satan there's no indication
in the original story that the snake has
anything to do with the Lord of all evil
it's a very weird conclusion that's been
drawn it's almost extra biblical because
there's almost no mention of Satan in
the Bible at all much less any direct
connection between the serpent and Satan
it's a very very strange idea but it's
part of this psychologization of evil
like what's the ultimate Predator what's
the ultimate predator
what's the enemy you Harbor in your own
heart who hates you
that's the ultimate predator
oh and when there's these images of Mary
uh
with her head in the stars and baby in
her arms and her foot on a snake it's
like well
that's the Eternal feminine heads in the
stars because she's oriented towards the
highest good and she's protecting her
infant from predators that could be
an actual Predator would that just be
the case throughout not just human
history but mammalian history could be
other people who are predators
could be men who are predators could be
her
who's a predator
the devouring mother
it's like well what's what's the
ultimate Locale of genuine evil well the
highest religious answer is that's in
you
that's the proper place to battle it out
and
I think that's true I think that's lit
it's literally and metaphorically true
and I I was convinced of that in part
because of social instance writings
because Soldier knitson identified the
totalitarian state with the willingness
of
the subjects of that state the subjects
and the perpetrators at the same time
to live by lies
no to no law no totalitarian state if
people don't lie
every time you lie in support of the
totalitarian state then you're the
perpetrator and that's a psychological
issue it's like you're gonna lie to get
along or not
say well what does it matter I'll go
along with it it's okay
we'll see how it matters
because it matters
and that's all psychodrama as far as I'm
concerned
fundamentally when it's properly placed
you've got plenty of problems to take
care of on your own front
that's where you should concentrate your
efforts
part of the cultural battle that we all
find ourselves enveloped in is partially
due to the claim that there's virtually
nothing other than the lust for power
and you know I would say
fair enough in some limited sense which
and that's
that bears directly on your question
because you see that as a Temptation
that might be powerful enough to bend
and distort you as you attempt to make
your way through let's say the halls of
power
well
[Music]
I heard recently from a reliable source
that Putin's conversion to Orthodox
Christianity might be genuine
and then you might think well if you're
atheistic
well that's not necessarily a good thing
or maybe you think it's a bad thing or
maybe you think it's
an irrelevant issue and you may also
think it's a lie but
I would say that
I would be more inclined to trust
someone who thinks there's something
higher than himself
and then you might say well what is it
that's higher than ourselves and that's
worth thinking about and we all need to
think about this regardless of the
particulars of our religious belief and
I would say
foreign
from a clinical perspective service to
others is really something
people who are depressed tend to use the
pronouns I and me much more frequently
than people who aren't depressed and I'm
not saying that people get depressed
because they're selfish I'm not saying
that at all I'm saying that one of the
way out one of the roots out of
depression appears to be an increase in
service to other people and I think the
reason for that is because we aren't
power mad demons at the core even though
we may be tempted by such things and
that we find the genuine meaning that
offsets genuine suffering in the genuine
service to others and I think it's a big
mistake to be cynical especially
prematurely about such things as
political activity because they're
necessary despite let's say they're
adversarial and uh and uh
party-centered nature partisan nature
you have to be clear about what you
serve and why
and that has to be held higher always
than mere Victory mere
operationalized Victory or instrumental
Victory it's a very very difficult thing
to to negotiate particularly because in
the political Realm
in some sense you have to defeat your
enemy right because you have to win the
election and the other people have to
lose it's a binary choice but so often I
see in partisan discussion the
proclivity to assume that all the ill
will and malevolence resides on the
other side of the chamber and that's a
big mistake and you can think about that
more deeply too is that we all have to
put we all need a place to place the
existence of malevolence
right because malevolence clearly exists
and we're all suffer from the weight of
malevolent history right because even
the grounds we walk on here which this
is a remarkable and wonderful place I
mean English soil is soaked with blood
just like the soil of every place in the
world that's part of the human Heritage
and all of us bear the marks of that
conflict in some sense in our souls
partly because of the possibility for us
to engage in that but also partly
because part of the reason we're here in
all this privilege is because of all
that catastrophe
well the best way to localize that
malevolence is inside you
right and to remember that the enemy
that you're fighting with the greatest
enemy that you ever fight with is in
your own heart and that'll also stop you
from confusing that true source of
malevolence let's say with your mere
political enemies and that isn't to say
that you won't encounter malevolent
Behavior although most of it in the
political sphere as it is everywhere
most of it is more ignorance than
malevolence although willful blindness
certainly plays a large role and so you
need to know what it is that you're
serving and I would say one of the ways
to do that practically are a couple of
ways to do that practically is you need
a good team around you the people you
really trust and who can watch you and
who do it with a certain degree of
impartiality and who are disagreeable
enough to talk to you when you do
something wrong so you need trusted
advisors and then the other thing I
would say is you really need to listen
to your constituents
because they will tell you what the
problems are if you listen to them and
if you really listen to them well then
you'll have your feet on the ground
which is where they should be and you'll
know what the problems are and you will
win elections
because what people really want from
their leaders is to be listened to and
then for those leaders to articulate
what they've heard in the halls of let's
say influence and Power
and so if you know those things if you
know you need to listen you need to get
in touch with the people you're
representing as regularly as you
possibly can and mostly to listen
um I knew a man in Canada who started a
political party which is a very
difficult thing to do and not only did
he start it but he wrote it to
sufficient success so that he became the
leader of the opposition in Canada
within about 10 years and I asked him
how he did that because it's like well
really how did you do that that's
actually really hard and he said he
would go out from constituency to
constituency and make his stump speeches
but what he really liked was the Q and
A's because people would tell him what
their problems were then he knew what
the problems were and out of the
dialogue would also emerge the answers
that the audience found compelling and
so not only would they tell him what the
problems were but they would tell him
the answers they would like to have it
have have what instituted to solve those
problems it's the same thing that
comedians do when they when they finast
finesse their acts in front of live
audiences before they practice them in
front of a large audience they lit they
tell jokes and the audience see their
laughs or they don't if they laugh then
you keep that joke and if they don't you
throw it out and soon you're just as
funny as the audience can possibly
manage and it's the same thing you can
also do that in a dark manner by the way
which is what Hitler did
so he could utter terrible things and
wait for response and collect those and
so then you become the embodiment of The
Shadow of Your people so I would
recommend that you probably don't do
that the next best predictor of Lifetime
success is conscientiousness well so and
of the of the two aspects of
conscientiousness say orderliness and
and industriousness the better predictor
is industriousness so the question is
well what can you do about your
industriousness and the answer to that
is
well that's kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component but
you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and I
think the best micro habits this is
partly to do with this future authoring
program processes I think the best thing
you can do with regards to your
conscientiousness is to set up some aims
for yourself goals that you actually
value and the future authoring program
helps people do that and basically it
does a situational analysis of it helps
you do a situational analysis of your
life more than a psychological analysis
I would say and so so the questions are
something like well all right you're
going to have to put some effort into
your life
and you need to be motivated to do that
and so what are the potential sources of
motivation well you could think about
them in in the big five manner you know
if you're extroverted you want friends
if you're agreeable you want an intimate
relationship if you're disagreeable you
want to win competitions if you're open
you want to engage in Creative activity
if you're high neuroticism you want
security okay so those are all sources
of potential motivation that you could
draw on that you could tailor to your
own you know your own personality but
then there are dimensions that you want
to consider your life across and so we
ask people about well you know if you
could have your life the way you wanted
it in three to five years if you were
taking care of yourself properly you
know what would you want from your
friendships what would you want from
your intimate relationship how would you
like to structure your family what do
you want for your career well how are
you going to use your time outside of
your job and how are you going to
regulate your mental physical mental and
physical health and maybe also your drug
and alcohol use because that's that's a
good place to Auger down you know
because alcoholism for example wipes out
you know five to ten percent of of
people so you want to keep that under
control and then
and then so maybe you know you you you
develop a vision of what your life what
you would like your life to be and that
Associates
the so the goal once the goal is
established and then you break down the
goal into micro processes that you can
implement the microprocesses become
rewarding in proportion in relation to
their uh causal association with the
goal and that tangles in your your
incentive reward system you know we
talked about the dopaminergic incentive
reward system and that's the thing that
keeps you moving forward and the way it
works is that it works better if it
produces positive emotion when it can
see you moving towards a valued goal
okay well what's the implication of that
better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out and so the more
valuable the goal in principle the more
the micro processes associated with that
goal start to take on a positive charge
and so what that means is well you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about the day you're ready to go and so
as far as I can tell what you do is you
specify your long-term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal you do
that you do that in some sense as a
unique individual you want to you want
to specify goals that make you say oh if
that could happen as a consequence of my
efforts it would clearly be worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something because doing nothing is easy
you just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy the question
is why would you ever do anything and
the answer to that has to be because
you've determined by some means that
it's worthwhile and then the next
question might be well where should you
look for worthwhile things and one would
be well you could consult your own
temperament and the other would be well
you kind of look at how look at what it
is that people accrue that's valuable
across the lifespan look look what so
you do a structural analysis of the
sub-components of human existence and
already did that you need a family you
need friends like like you don't need to
have all these things but you better
have most of them family friends career
educational goals plans for you know
time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health Etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's a bad
that's a bad deal for you
so
so once you but once you set up that
that goal structure let's say and that's
really in many in many ways that's what
you should be doing at universities is
that's exactly what you should be doing
is trying to figure out
who it is that you're trying to be
right and you aim at that and then you
use everything you learn as a means of
building that person that you want to be
and
and I really mean want to be I don't
mean should be even those things those
things are going to overlap and it's
important to distinguish between those
because that's partly and this is back
down to the micro routine analysis so I
started saying well you're going to try
to make yourself more industrious okay
number one specify your damn goals
because how are you going to hit
something if you don't know what it is
that isn't going to happen and often
people won't specify their goals too
because they don't like to specify
conditions for failure so if you keep
yourself all vague and foggy which is
real easy because that's just a matter
of not doing as well then you don't know
when you fail
and people might say well I really don't
want to know when I fail because that's
painful so I'll keep myself blind about
when I fail that's fine except you'll
fail all the time then you just won't
know it until you've failed so badly
that you're done and that can easily
happen by the time you're 40.
so so I would recommend that you don't
let that happen so that's willful
blindness right you could have known but
you chose not to okay so once you get
your goal structure set up you think
okay if I can have this life it looks
like that might be worth living despite
the fact that it's going to be you know
anxiety provoking and threatening and
there's going to be some suffering and
loss involved in all of that obviously
the goal is to to have a vision for your
life such that all things considered
that justifies your effort before you
can be a painter who can paint what's
beyond mere memory you you have to
inculcate that discipline skill and a
lot of that is painful repetition and
hard grinding work it's the sacrifice of
the present for the future but once you
manage that then things open up and
virtually everything you learn of value
is like that's very very very difficult
to learn to write and there's arbitrary
arbitrary rules that you have to follow
and bind yourself to and while you're
learning those rules the probability
that you have any creative freedom to
speak of or any facility with the rules
is very low you're you're a rank
beginner and and even to some degree
whatever creativity you have is going to
have to be stifled while you're passing
through that that Keyhole but if you
pass through it then something massive
opens up on the other side and it is
definitely the case that
disciplinary institutions universities
are exactly that is there places of
guidance and and they're places to
encourage people to develop the
discipline that's necessary to see
beyond the discipline I mean that's why
we have disciplines right I mean the
words aren't there by accident you have
to narrow yourself first and then you
can broaden outward and so that's and
that's part of the process of maturation
that part of the that's part of the
sacrifice of childhood say in childhood
you're nothing but potential but it's
not realized and you don't know how to
realize it and so then the question is
well how do you get to a point where you
realize the potential and the answer is
you sacrifice almost all of it to a
single Direction This is Nietzsche's
commentary on the Catholic Church he's a
great admirer of the Catholic Church
despite the fact that he was also a
radical critic critic of Christianity
said the cat see the thing about the
Catholic church is that it forced
everything to be interpreted within a
single explanatory framework and that
was a discipline and once that
discipline was established then the
disciplined mind could explode in every
direction which is precisely what
happened and so and and and that's the
thing about growing up is that when
you're a teenager and a young adult you
have to sacrifice everything you could
have been as a child to be the one thing
that you're aiming at but then that
opens up and and the universities are
part and parcel of that process and you
need the guidance because the the the
library is too large to wander through
it unaided you have to make a decision
in your life and this is
this is a decision and I would say that
it's a voluntary element of Faith
because it isn't exactly evidence-based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so Faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe Faith sometimes
means putting a stake in this sand and
saying here is where I stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you you know pledge allegiance to a
friend you have a best friend and you
want to maintain that friendship as long
as you possibly can it's it's it's a
decision of Faith
um maybe you do that when you decide a
career when you go to university because
you could have done something else right
but you chose that so that's where you
put your faith
um and like I said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe okay so back to God is
love well I'm going to talk about being
first instead of God
um and being is the totality of
experience that we're going to Define
that it that way for the purposes of
this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature being is what you
experience as a conscious creature it
includes all your emotions all your
motivations all your subjective
experience as well as everything that's
objective Okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered it's a useful
move of Faith to act as if you love
being and if you love something then you
want the best in it to flourish and so
maybe you decide deep in your soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an end that makes everything
that's good better that that's the best
way to live to make everything that's
good better and maybe to restrict the
development of everything that's
malevolent and evil within yourself and
in the broader world insofar as you're
able to do that and so I think that's an
expression of Love is that because when
you love something you care for it and
the proper attitude towards being I
think is care
and so so that's one element of God is
love God being
analogous in some way to being
um now we could look at God more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being is good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and maybe that's the
most effective means of having existence
open its heart to you so for example you
know if you love other people you want
the best for them you want the best and
you deserve the best in them if you love
them and you trust them courageously so
you open yourself up to them I don't
think it's unreasonable to assume that
that's how you elicit the best from them
the best that can be elicited you're
going to get hurt sometimes and betrayed
but that's going to happen no matter
what approach you take I think that's
the most effective approach and that is
perhaps the most effective approach to
existence per se to approach it with
love and courage and and so that's how
that looks to me
is it a feeling like loving a person yes
I think it is I think it is a feeling
like loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for a child your child your
your brother your sister a family member
it's the generalization of that to the
broader domain of of existence to
broader domain of domains of existence
and I think that's a skill in some sense
right I mean if you're good at loving
and caring for your family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that it's
very difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable that
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that and so you see that when
you have a job or you and you encounter
a boss who takes you under his or her
wing and helps develop you or you find a
teacher who's particularly inspiring or
you work for an entrepreneur who's
inspiring and who also opens doors for
you
um they're acting with love as far as
I'm concerned they want the best in them
to serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and that's
the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for God's sake
so can love balance out the crushing
responsibility that's a sophisticated
question
I don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness and sort of a cold
virtue I don't know if it balances out
the crushing responsibility but I think
it's the emotional analog to the
crushing responsibility right so maybe
there's love and Duty and they run
parallel in in if you're an ethical
person that's not all there is to ethics
but you know love and Duty they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent
um entities you don't have to
necessarily have done anything wrong for
things to get completely out of control
it's a terrifying Doctrine but it's not
a hopeless Doctrine because it still
says that there's a way forward there's
a pathway forward and the pathway
forward is to adopt a mode of being that
has some nobility so that you can
tolerate yourself and perhaps even have
some respect for yourself as someone
who's capable of standing up in the face
of that terrible vulnerability and
suffering and that the pathway forward
as far as the existentialists are
concerned is by well certainly by the
avoidance of Deceit particularly in
language but also by the adoption of
responsibility for the conditions of
existence and some attempt on your part
to actually Rectify them and the thing
that's so interesting about that is
there are two as far as I'm concerned
and some of this is from Clinical
experience you know if you take people
and I've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over decades long periods what they
could be like if they were who they were
if they said if they spoke their being
forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world in a number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now my experience
is with people that we're probably
running at about 51 percent of our
capacity something I mean you can think
about this yourselves I often ask
undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying uh watching things on YouTube
that not only do you not want to watch
that you don't even care about that make
you feel horrible about watching after
you're done that's probably four hours
right there you know what you think well
that's 20 25 hours a week it's 100 hours
a month that's two and a half full work
weeks it's half a year of work weeks per
year and if your time is worth
twenty dollars an hour which is a
radical underestimate it's probably more
like 50 if you think about it in terms
of deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting
fifty thousand dollars a year is a way
bigger catastrophe than it would be for
me to waste it because I'm not going to
last nearly as long and so if your life
isn't everything it could be you could
ask yourself well what would happen if
you just stopped wasting the
opportunities that are in front of you
you be who knows how much more efficient
10 times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the Pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all
bundled together in an absolutely
pathological package if people stopped
really really trying just to make things
worse we have no idea how much better
they would get just because of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment both of which are are are our
major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt it isn't merely that your
fate depends on whether or not you get
your act together and to what degree you
decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate it's the fate of everyone that
you're networked with and so you know
you think well there's nine billion
seven billion people in the world we're
going to Peak at about 9 billion by the
way and then it'll decline rapidly but
seven billion people in the world and
who are you you're just one little dust
moat among that seven billion and so it
really doesn't matter what you do or
don't do but that's simply not the case
it's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network you're a node in
a network of course that's even more
true now that we have social media
you'll you'll know a thousand people at
least over the course of your life and
they'll know a thousand people each and
that puts you one person away from a
million and two persons away from a
billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do they're like dropping
a stone in a pond the ripples move
outward and they affect things in ways
that you can't fully comprehend and it
means that the things that you do and
that you don't do are far more important
than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but I mean if
you really ask yourself would you be so
sure if you had the choice I can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price I pay is that nothing matters
or I can reverse it and everything
matters
but I have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
now when you say well nihilists suffered
dreadfully because there's no meaning in
their life and they still suffer yeah
but the advantage is they have no
responsibility
so that's the payoff and I actually
think that's the motivation say well I
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is some meaningless
suffering but you can always whine about
that and people will feel sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the Martyr so that's a pretty
good deal All Things Considered
especially when they are when the
alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well with
sojournitzen figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit or even more
importantly if it's a light if it's a
place you'd like to visit and take all
your family and friends because that's
what happened in the 20th century
foreign
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome for Jordan Peterson's 12 rules
that will change your life check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I was reading these
these articles on lobsters and I I I
came across this this finding that
lobsters lobsters govern their postural
flexion